hey baysiders it's me again dexter or
you may know me as my character devonte
from save by the bell if you thought the
easter eggs and throwbacks from season
one were amazing this next season is
going to knock it out of the max i i
mean park
keep your eyes open for all of the
nostalgic moments in season 2 of the
peacock original series saved by the
bell
let's get started in episode 1 the whole
gang is back together to celebrate an
old friend screech
this scene is rich with nostalgia max
the magician comes out with the
screech's spaghetti burger this serves
as a memorial for the actor who plays
screech dustin diamond who sadly passed
away they even bring out kevin the robot
a robot that's greece created in the
original
you all remember how slater used to
wrestle in high school
well he started up a wrestling team in
episode 2 and has some help from an old
teammate moose
mark clayman is back and this time is an
assistant wrestling coach
mr dewey's back this season as well and
he's as awkward as ever in season two
episode three he's the teacher who tells
daisy and guilty stop being cute
come on mr dewey another original cast
member who's back this season is matt
kaminski he drops in during episode 5 to
deliver sand requisitions to mack who
then forces daisy to sign for each
individual sand grain mac why you got to
be like that not this time mack morris
the cameos just keep on coming
the record producer that almost signed
the girls to his label in the 90s is
back and this time he's ready to sign
devonta
i may be biased but he deserves it
we'll let you in on a little secret that
record producer is the show's executive
producer franco barrio what's up boss of
course our easter eggs go beyond just
cameos from our favorite classic
characters flashback to the sweetheart
dance where zach tricked kelly into
being his date well in the first episode
of this new season the sweetheart dance
finally happens and lexi and jamie even
wear replicas of the hearts that zack
and the gang wore in the original series
you may have missed another small knob
but no need to worry we got you
when lexi says you were smart to climb
out the window when you did that's a nod
to how zack used to climb into jesse's
bedroom window
season two takes easter eggs to the next
level with this direct reference to the
zac tapes the episode is even called the
mack tapes zach must have mentioned that
time he hit subliminal messages in the
george michael song don't leave with
your love because mac uses the same song
to do the exact same thing oh mack too
bad you didn't learn from your father's
mistakes later in the episode when
jessie mentions cut day she is referring
to the episode from the original series
cut day when she skipped a trip to the
beach in order to protest styrofoam cups
looks like this time she got to do both
are these styrofoam yeah is there a
problem big problem bub and we'll let
you in on another little secret the
restaurant that slater takes jessie to
is the same location they filmed the
original season 4 episode moving along
to episode 3 keep your eyes wide open
for starters the episode title 1 900
crushed is the same name as an episode
in the original
in the teen lion scene the students are
using the same phone and poster design
that the students use the first time
around we first did teen line back in
the 90s and fortunately my old mentor
richard belding left me
the training manual the bayside versus
valley rivalry is still going strong and
it's obvious mack has learned the ropes
from zach he infiltrates valley as a
fake student and even steals their
mascot like father like son
slater has always worked on his physical
strength but now he's focusing more on
his mental muscles by going into
counseling where he realizes some
shocking details like the fact that he
had a mother who was mentioned once
i think i had a mom
and how about that time slater had a
sister that we never saw again
yeah he figures that out too hmm
interesting and no one ever talked about
it slater acknowledging his forgotten
family isn't the only time a character
breaks the fourth wall this season no no
come on not the fantasy border now that
lisa's around more often we get to enjoy
her great fashion sense
the green jacket she's wearing in
episode six
yeah that's a nod to all of the lime
color outfits she wore in high school
and that's not the only time miss turtle
brings back the iconic 90s styles
peep jesse and kelly's high school
outfits own lisa's mannequins wait
i did wear this in high school if you're
watching the career episode and think
you're seeing double it's because you
are all of the signs were directly
inspired to match the career day zak and
his friends went to
did you catch when slater said
i didn't even learn spanish until the
college years
you mean when you were in college yeah
college years
and these are the high school years
that's how everyone says it you know
that was a blatant reference to save by
the bell the college years this season
we get a lot of kelly throwbacks like at
the time that kelly took a trip to paris
with some random photographer he took me
to paris for one month
it was cool looks like she still has
fond memories of that trip speaking of
trips kelly talks about that time when
she gave up her prestigious semester at
sea to marry zack i love you and i want
to marry you now and she realizes that
maybe it wasn't the best decision if
fate didn't make the decision then who
did
my dumbass
in episode 9 we get a nod to kelly and
zach's breakup with a new breakup at the
same table the table isn't the only
thing these scenes have in common
daisy and gill if that's even his real
name
have the last dance just like zach and
kelly did after their breakup
now i'm sure you noticed that jesse and
slater kissed the end of episode nine
well in episode 10 they have a series of
flashbacks that actually features the
same set from the college years dorm
room this episode also showcases one of
the most important things in save by the
bell history the spirit competition
between valley and bayside this
competition features tests of physical
strength and agility that mirrors an
episode from the classic series timeout
time man looks like it's time to say
goodbye but did you spot any other
easter eggs and throwbacks let us know
in the comments watch the all-new season
of saved by the bell streaming now on
peacock man i love this school
[Music]
you